[Musica]
quindi indagare il reale le inchieste
giornalistiche cercano di rivelare o
almeno attentano di rivelare gli abusi
di potere e portano avanti la storia
fino a quando il sistema non è costretto
a rispondere i giornalisti d'inchiesta
cercano di dare e di offrire delle
informazioni affinché voi tutti le
persone possiate prendere delle
decisioni sulle vostre vite e anche la
democrazia stessa
si basa sulla volontà dei giornalisti
anche sulla volontà dei giornalisti che
non smettono mai di mettere a rischio la
propria vita per regalarci un pezzetto
di verità in più come partendo da perché
la domanda perché che una delle cinque w
del giornalismo e non so se le conoscete
sono perché come dove quando e chi
ovviamente in inglese fin da quando ero
piccolo io ho sempre cercato di provare
il perché delle cose di tutto ciò che
stava dietro ciò che vedevo e percepivo
ma fare il giornalista non era la mia
primaria vocazione insomma io non
sognavo di fare il giornalista
io sognavo di fare il fisico nucleare
poi successivamente l'unica scissione
che ho ottenuto è stata quella degli
albumi dai tuorli proprio grazie a un
tutorial di sonia peronaci che ringrazio
studiai e continua a farlo pianoforte e
musica e anche in questa disciplina
ho sempre cercato di capire il perché il
perché delle composizioni il perché
della teoria musicale il perché delle
interpretazioni e quindi credo che le
cinque w del giornalismo possono essere
ritrovate anche nella musica e quindi al
centro abbiamo il compositore che porta
con sé tutto il suo bagaglio socio
culturale e che l'ha trasformato poi in
composizioni nelle sue opere attraverso
le note da qui dalla mia passione per i
dati ha iniziato a crescere in me la
volonta di studiare come le persone
interagiscono tra loro e come si
comportano in un dato contesto quindi
parallelamente agli studi al
conservatorio ho iniziato a studiare
sociologia all'università è così insomma
piano piano grazie anche alla mia
passione per i dati per le matrici per
il metodo scientifico ho iniziato a
capire che la musica fosse una forma
d'arte che coniugasse al meglio
creatività e scienza
la musica la musica e genio e guizzo e
interpretazione neanche rigore verità e
riproducibilità come dice il musicologo
quirino principe la musica classica non
è così corretto definirla classica
perché avremmo magari una sorta di
recinto troppo stretto per includerla ma
è meglio chiamarla musica forte la
musica forte la musica che ci si muove
che ci fa camminare che ci fa scoprire
dell'altro
la musica forte ad esempio potrebbe
essere anche il jazz il blues
per me la musica di nina simone e musica
forte come quella di duke ellington
quella di oltre petrucciani ha così come
quella di beethoven o liberti
alla base di questa musica forte oltre
esserci come detto il genio e la
creatività che portano alla cultura la
storia e il racconto c'è anche il rigore
le tipicità dati dal tempo e dalle
frequenze quindi anche dalle onde sonore
che non sono altro che scale tonali su
cui la musica sale e scende
ebbene io ritrovo tutto questo nella
sociologia e nel giornalismo
finora non ho ancora partecipato
inchiesta giornalistica con ricadute
sulla politica ma e non ho messo a
rischio la mia vita la mia riservatezza
e la mia privacy ma anche ora questa
mattina infine giugno c'è qualcuno là
fuori un giornalista che sta mettendo a
rischio la propria vita per regalarci un
pezzetto di verità in più io con la mia
ultima inchiesta super eroi nascosti
pubblicata sulla stampa o però cercato e
ottenuto una ricaduta sociale è stato un
progetto che ha avuto una progettazione
una realizzazione nell'arco di un intero
anno per le strade di torino in cui ho
cercato di raccontare la vita dei
senzatetto e per realizzarla mi sono
basato proprio sulla musica forte sulla
musica classica sul contrappunto
melodico sull'armonia e sul ritmo bene
il contrappunto in musica è
l'espressione che definisce la pratica
di contrapporre a un cantus firmus ossia
una melodia una nuova melodia per
farvela semplice quando voi partecipate
guardato ascoltato un concerto di musica
classica
avrete sicuramente visto che la parte
del canto melodico viene effettuata da
strumenti come ad esempio i violini
flauti il pianoforte stesso ebbene nella
scrittura contrappuntistica lo scopo
principale che si vuole ottenere
l'indipendenza di tutte queste voci
melodiche che poi messi insieme formano
un tutto polifonico che funziona ma per
spiegarvela magari con delle parole di
un compositore e fagottista john run
statunitense ancora in vita
lui dice che scrivere una bella canzone
è difficile
ma scrivere canzoni che siano
indipendentemente belle e che poi messi
insieme formano un tutto polifonico
ancor più bello estremamente più
complesso bene le inchieste
giornalistiche sono proprio queste ossia
trovare lo spazio per ogni voce per voce
contrapposte indipendenti al fine di
ottenere una melodia la melodia data dal
tema dell'inchiesta ma un'opera in
un'opera non basta la melodia serve
anche l'armonia e serve e serve il ritmo
il ritmo viene offerto dal tempo e dalla
velocità il tempo sono i cosiddetti
battiti per minuto
l'avrete magari sentiti insomma
all'inizio di un brano c'è sempre un
simbolo che può essere una quartina è un
tempo ad esempio 107 bpm i battiti per
minuto e la velocità invece esprime
l'andamento del pezzo quindi anche lì
avrebbe ascoltato magari adagio allegro
ma non solo il ritmo anche il m che
mentre la ricorrenza per periodica degli
accenti quindi qua parliamo dai quattro
quarti del 3 ottavi e cosa ci dà il
ritmo in un'inchiesta
i dati i dati ci danno ci danno questo
ritmo perché ci danno lo spunto su come
scrivere l'inter inchiesta raccontarla e
ci danno il metro e quindi l'intera
architettura dell'inchiesta i dati sono
veri sono verificabili
i dati sono scientifici i dati ci
permettono di smontare le bugie ci
permettono di diradare la fuffa
ma facciamo un esempio il governo
italiano ora il potere parla di un
un'invasione di immigrati ma è davvero
così
esiste un invasione di immigrati i dati
ci dicono qualcosa di diverso ci dicono
che dal primo gennaio del 2000 e 18 al
26 giugno che l'ultimo giorno in cui ho
cercato questi dati per realizzare il
grafico che vedete ci sono stati 16.500
51 sbarco
nel 2017 nello stesso periodo erano
addirittura 73 mila circa
bene non soffermiamoci sul perché di
questa disparità di dati ma sulla
differenza tra lo storytelling politico
e la verità c'è un'enorme differenza
un'enorme differenza nel c'è stato un
calo dell 84 per cento rispetto al 2017
e cerca dell 82 per cento rispetto allo
stesso periodo del 2016
invasione e la cosa buffa che questi
dati hanno come fonte il ministero
dell'interno
quindi significa che lo stesso ministro
del ministero dell'interno non gliene
anche letti ma torniamo a noi
come vi dicevo abbiamo il contrappunto
melodico abbiamo il ritmo e infine
abbiamo l'armonia l'armonia musicale e
lo sviluppo delle relazioni delle note
in termini di intervalli di tono sia
simultanee che che che susseguenti di
arpeggio di progressione individuo e
determina la tonalità del brano quindi
in che cosa ritroviamo l'armonia
all'interno di un inchiesta
beh secondo me la ritroviamo nelle foto
e nei video
nell'infografica la ritroviamo nel in
tutto ciò che è la la scrittura il tono
della scrittura e anche il tono del
racconto se è invece trattasi di un
inchiesta video io credo quindi che la
commistione tra tecnica e sensibilità
all'interno di un inchiesta via la sua
armonia tecnica nella capacità di
utilizzare gli strumenti da maestri e
sensibilità perché serve anche occhio
percezione flessibilità cognitiva e
intelligenza empatica
come accennavo prima la mia ultima
inchiesta super eroi nascosti e
costruita musicalmente e con questo
modello continua a produrre i nuovi
progetti su cui sto lavorando ora su cui
lavorerò in futuro il ritmo in questa
inchiesta lo creato attraverso i dati
che ovviamente sono dati verificabili
quindi con fonti sicure alcuni dei quali
mi sono stati dati dal governo stesso
del comune di torino altri invece li ho
recuperati da associazioni sul
territorio nazionale o anche da indagini
che ho fatto io direttamente in loco con
questionari con domande poi l'armonia
l'armonia e l'abbiamo data con
innanzitutto il web design perché questa
inchiesta è stata pensata per essere
fruita da computer e dispositivi mobili
quindi il web design la user experience
è qualcosa che è estremamente importante
in un lavoro di questo tipo ma non solo
trattandosi appunto di un prodotto
pensato per il web
abbiamo cercato di dare delle
infografiche come quella che vedete qui
ma che siano interattive quindi che le
persone chiunque potesse riuscire a
interagire con quello che stava
guardando e leggende ma abbiamo anche
fatto delle fotografie dei video delle
interviste perché tutto questo
nell'armonia di un'inchiesta
serve per portare il lettore nei luoghi
in cui noi siamo stati in cui noi noi
abbiamo visto ciò che andavamo a
indagare quindi qua ad esempio questa è
una fotografia che abbiamo scattato
all'interno di un dormitorio e vi
assicuro che quella sera in cui siamo
stati lì quel dormitorio era stato
pulito appositamente perché sapevano che
dovevamo arrivare noi e vi assicuro che
nei giorni successivi non si trovava più
quel quella pulizia nonostante potete
vedere delle cose non proprio gradevole
e ve lo posso assicurare perché dopo
questa inchiesta sono entrato poi nella
croce rossa
il comitato di torino per cercare di
continuare quello che gli avevo iniziato
a fare con lavoro di inchiesta
e infine infine abbiamo la melodia il
contrappunto il contrappunto di questa
inchiesta cioè le storie lo storytelling
ho raccolto tantissime storie di
senzatetto decine e decine
ho passato giorni e notti insieme a loro
per strada a torino ad ascoltarli
qui poi nell'inchiesta ho raccolto otto
storie e per proteggere la loro privacy
non sono otto storie come dire che si
configurano realmente in quelle che sono
le vite raccontate ma sono un mix di
tutto quello che ho ascoltato bene in
queste storie sono ho cercato di far
capire perché i senzatetto sono sono
nascosti senzatetto sono nascosti perché
non li vediamo noi non siamo abituati a
guardare in basso non ce ne accorgiamo e
non ci soffermiamo mai a parlare con
loro che in realtà sarebbe ciò che
vogliono davvero quello che di cui hanno
bisogno perché parlando con loro
loro potrebbero ricordarsi di un buon
motivo per tornare a lottare a vivere e
potremo ricordarci anche noi
ho cercato di dare una sorta di
collegamento tra i senzatetto è qualcosa
di che ricordasse supereroi e cosa non
altro dei supereroi della marvel o
pensate supereroi della marvel perché
hanno tutti delle storie molto complesso
molto difficili e ho conosciuto una
giovanissima ragazza di un centro di
accoglienza di torino che mi ha aiutato
a creare delle maschere di questi
supereroi fatte appositamente male con
della stoffa riciclata molto colorate
che potessero in qualche modo far capire
anche chi si celava dietro quella
maschera infatti nell'inchiesta voi
potete prima vedere una fotografia del
senzatetto con la maschera puoi scoprire
la sua storia e dopo togliere la sua
maschera ad esempio lui e jonas e jonas
a fare questo è uno di quelli che si è
divertito di più
e ci ha aiutato moltissimo beh vi lascio
con questo la musica ci insegna ad
ascoltare e questo nel giornalismo è
davvero fondamentale
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]